my name is Noah with Steven Smith for
much of my life I was known as razor I
was an armed robber in London for over
35 years spent faced who use in prison
and I'm now editor of the prison
magazine Ian's outside always the only
one arrested none of my pals were ever
nicked for it they never knew that they
were and I'll stand there on my own at
the age of 47 or 49 and you hear a judge
up there giving you eight life sentences
plus 80 years in concurrent sentences
and is actually saying in this summing
up they have shall never released you
kind of figure your life is over you
know I mean that is a turning point I
just thought to myself this is it you
know that's the end of it I'm gonna die
in prison
[Music]
[Music]
got a sucky apart from all the peeling
ceiling this is a typical prison cell
ready I mean I've been in so many of
these it's unreal sometimes in a cell
this size you'll have three people so
you won't have bunk beds on that side or
what single bed this side but it is
pretty much the same as most cells I
mean you know these were all caught in
like this stage the sinks in the toilets
at one stage this wouldn't have had
anything at all it would have been a
bare cell and I've got to say there are
cells in the system in about 20
different prisons that are even smaller
than this probably around about half the
size the length of a bed is the size of
the cell and they can't put toilets in
them this is actually the segregation or
as we use to call it at the old days
before PC in a punishment block because
it's where you're taking it through your
punishment and you would spend your time
alone in this cell or cell very similar
to this with absolutely nothing there is
a toilet in the cell now 20 years ago
the wouldn't have been a toilet and the
sink it would have been just the bed the
table a chair and a piss pot it was a
rule of silence down there so you
couldn't sing you couldn't whistle you
couldn't speak the only person you saw
where the officers who came and put your
meals into the cell you got exercise
every two weeks for half an hour you got
a shower every 10 weeks and basically it
was a bit of a star exists to be on a
bit of a living hell they tell you
before they come forward a chap through
the door get down the back of the cell
with your face to the wall if you didn't
comply you wouldn't get fed so the
prisoner would be standing at the back
wall with his face to the wall and the
screws would use a broom handle to push
the meal in on a plastic plate and there
it would lie amongst all the ex woman
and once that was done and that's all
you've heard three times today was that
and then bomb they got
when you think that the most dangerous
people in the outside world
GBH merchants murderers people who would
take your eye out without reason they
end up in prison so you end up with it
instead of one in your neighborhood you
end up with everybody next door you all
packed in like this and you never know
who people are and you can't take a risk
in prison
the queen of prison violence is do it
first and do it fast so and do it and
proper put them out of the game because
if you don't put someone out of the game
they're coming back on the wing and it's
going to start again so you've got a
really hurt somebody so that they get
shipped to hospital went outside the
prison
and why's they coming back at you
tomorrow and that's how you live in
prison
paranoid brutal and violent there's a
thing called jerking which is when you
get three or four-year with sharp
weapons sharp pointed weapons and you
just steamed in one person and stabbed
them as many times as you can leaving a
move a thousand it's called teabagging
will heat to begging is a different
finger here are not imprisoned
teabagging these stubborn people many
times leaving a thousand perforations
that's where it comes from tea bagging
but hot water with sugar every prison
landing had a boiler I don't see when it
would have been over there and you get
boiling water out this to make tea
coffee whatever and what a lot of
prisoners use that there was if they
really want it to work someone fill up
their two pint jug plastic jug with hot
boiling water out of it pour a pound of
sugar into it throw it over somebody it
strips this skin and sticks to your face
it will use a horrific weapon anything
you find in a prison can be turned into
a weapon I mean this was a favorite this
is a prison food tray everyone will be
issued with one of these at mealtimes
now this is stainless steel the weighs
quite a bit and I've seen many people
after head split open release just crack
them a favorite trick in the old days in
Boston was the whole tea tray like that
if you were going to do someone who was
sitting down and that age there is very
sharp and jammy into their face if
someone wanted to get you and you were
in this shower I mean take a look at it
it's pretty isolated
there's enough room for two people in
here maybe free if you're lucky now
imagine you were standing there naked
having a shower the three guys in masks
come through fully clothed and start
stabbing you in the shell which is what
they normally do they'll get you when
you're naked they know you've got my
weapon with you and because you're naked
and that's the most dangerous time in
prison is when you make it in the shower
not because something includes to have
sex with the hope it's because somebody
wants to hurt you severely so this is
the best time to do it when you're
vulnerable preferably when you just
started washing your hair and the
shampoos in your eyes they will be over
at the door and they'll come flying in
and boom that beer I mean I can almost
guarantee them if some of these paint
there's gonna be bloodstains on these
walls because there isn't most prison
chairs I think this is the kitchens yeah
a lot of people would like to work in
these places but they're also very
dangerous apartment they slop they put
out the prisoners that to eat there was
a lot of knives and stuff like that kept
in here and in fact in Parkers prison a
few years ago the guy was stabbed to
death in the kitchens a murderer with a
carving knife by a sex offender if you
work in the kitchens you don't have to
wait a slop you put out you make your
own food you know you make it to how you
like it so you all right it's a case of
one more white Jake and basically I've
seen people stirring the big tears or
the porridge urns and just spitting in
it occasionally you like you know I made
the ugly white youth they could keep you
out of the kitchens was if you had a
blood related disease that you could
poison the whole prison if you had
appetizers they wouldn't let you in work
in the kitchens although I do know
people with habit science who worked in
the kitchen if you add H IV or AIDS you
couldn't work in the kitchens and that
was in case and a lot of what you've got
imagine there's a lot of mad people
there's a lot of bad people and insane
people in prison that people with HIV
would have no problem cutting a finger
and dripping blood in your food they do
the sex offenders you know and it was
just one of those things and I mean what
you gotta take from that is prisoners on
the whole and not really you know it
totally
people they're in prison for a reason
and doing strange things especially with
the people that have mental illnesses
it's kind of theory go for them you know
it's standards so you could end up with
someone in a prison working in the
kitchens who's got HIV and his trip and
his blood regularly into the food in the
hope of contaminating everybody else he
happens the thing you've gotta take on
board is prison is so paranoid it
prisoners are so paranoid
and we're all stuck in this one little
small place and it looks massive on film
but seriously this is a small area the
whole prison and you never go anywhere
and you're all there so the paranoia is
absolutely tremendous and you never know
when someone's plotting up on you or
someone wants to stab you or someone
wants to scold you so everybody's in a
heightened state of awareness so um
someplace that those make a loud noise
and it all kicks off you know that's the
thing about prison this it's very
violent place in a very paranoid place
as well gradually over the last say five
or six years legal highs they're not
legalized anymore but say synthetic
opiates and Cynthia counts and cannabis
in prison has become massive it's easy
to smuggling it's cheap and it's changed
so much that what they do now they get
the wing numpty or the wing junkie they
get a parcel in and I find an idiot on
the wing and say come in to want some
spice and they're testing on them so
what it do is they give it to them and
they watch what happens to them and if
the guy in life flies out of cell which
they quite often though and jumps over
the landing which is pretty common down
onto the main even though that will stop
you dieting you won't stop you're
breaking buns or being seriously hurt
because that's still while so then they
find out you know what the strength of
it is and what it's going to do to you
and then they'll sell it around the
prison so I believe there's been
something like 69 this in the last two
years from legalizing prison which when
you think about hip people should be
screaming up 69 people have died in our
prisons down to smoking legalize or
illegal Heisler so yeah I mean drugs in
prison are very big if you were if you
ask yourself why would anyone need drugs
in prison I've gotta tell you hot or a
ten-hour shift most prison officers well
again have a stiff drink there any of
the ten airs supervising imagine living
in it 24 hours a day
those weak sometimes for decades I mean
if you're going to only see these walls
every day for the next 10 years you need
something when you'd be aren't your door
when you're out to smash the sameness of
prison just to relieve the boredom and
that's why a lot of prisoners tournament
drugs when they come into prison well
like you know the life I've been talking
about it takes something really really
big to kind of shake it out and I was
doing way of life sentences in white
more prison in 2001 and I came back from
the OP like one night and if you see any
sort of holy man on the on the landings
in prison in the top security gels like
priest a vicar a man whatever rabbi you
know that there to deliver bad news
they don't come on the Romans on their
stake there to deliver bad news it's too
dangerous for them
can I came back from the hot plate with
a big Judy drug dealer called bud and
just you know I sort of elbowed him and
I when look I see the priest at the end
of Lent know which someone's in for some
bad news and when I got up to myself so
that was me and it was my 19 year old
son Johnson food diet on the outside and
I was devastated obviously you know you
cut it's really hard to explain that
devastated you are I mean that when the
priests trying to tell me when I
realized that he was coming for me I
just flipped and I said man I said don't
talk to me I said get away from me and
he went boy I have to tell you I said
you don't have to tell me nothing I said
when go away I said get out myself
anyway off he's went and closed it he
got a screw the closet door don't tell
me through the closed door in case I
attacked him so I asked to be let out
went to the phone phone up my arm Mike's
wife and then it turned out his true and
then I mean that that was kind of bad
enough I started thinking to myself you
know
I'm stuck in a top security prison one
of the diamond geezers walk around give
me the pig and and my son is dead
outside and I can't comfort my family so
then the next step was I had to try and
apply it to go to my son's few and I
went to they they so let the security
governor in one more at the time what
had been a member of staff in Rochester
25 years previous and I had actually
broken his mates jaw and he hated me for
it and he always used to dig me out and
I had to go through this man and begging
to be allowed out for my son's funeral
and he took great pleasure in begging me
begging and then say no and I went away
I fought about it and my fault you know
I've spent all these years in prison
building myself up as this ogre you know
attacking prison officers styling wires
trying to cause trouble everywhere I
went and then I want something from them
and they within their rights to say no
and I realized I brought it all on
myself this didn't come overnight
I wasn't that logical just came over a
period of thinking of them about three
or four weeks whilst I was in grief and
what happened was as is the usual case
that the prisoners heard about it on my
wing Oh seriously dangerous men are mean
household names and they come down and
citizen Liberty they're not let you go
to a funeral so what we're going to do
is on the day of the funeral we're going
to attack the screws you know in honor
of your son inaudible was that they said
we're gonna get a load of washing up
liquid spread it all over the landing
you said we're going to get armed then
we're going to ring the bell and when
it's crews come running order they fall
over we're gonna statement do as many as
we can and I could see they was doing it
like as a sort of tribute in a fatality
sense which would be but they've been
doing it so for me to show some of their
and and I thought about it overnight and
they're not from know I said I thought
my legacy muscle as legacy could be a
load of prison officers being bashed up
and what more prison so I'm thinking
another way then and that it was that my
son's death or not
the kind of funeral that actually made
me you know reevaluate my life and find
out you know where I was going and what
was happening don't forget at that time
I thought was never getting out of
prison but I still had the urge to kind
of change my ways sort of because of
Joe's death so that was the real major
catalyst that made me show you my ways
in prison
[Music]
[Music]
you